this never wavering never deviating from
the strategy it's tiring it's exhausting
it's also unfortunately for all of us
the cost of entry to be successful
[Music]
that's just what has to happen have to
figure that out that's that uh that's
not up for debate
[Music]
you
[Music]
and and I'm not sold that I don't know
if that makes me a good guy or a bad guy
it's just my it's my natural state to
slightly over deliver as close to the
middle as possible and I like that
[Music]
[Music]
congratulations Mary man did you enjoy
it
projector came out of the turnaround hey
Niles it's me Gary Vaynerchuk your CEO
cam love you so much congratulations
what an amazing amazing day I just want
to make a couch video and tell you guys
how much I love you how much I am so sad
that I'm not there and most of all how
proud I am that there's so many Vayner
rights gain rights the news that's
vaynermedia peeps at the at the wedding
where's your ring thank you so much
thank you so much were you able to use
any of crushin oh yeah
so literally on an authentic level to
the business for the certain place you
read the book you did certain things
good things happened everything yep yeah
great that's what I want that's what I
want real pleasure
yes well thank you what is it
oh man I'm pumped so what is this okay
once I get it by the way not only do I
get it I think I might just wear it all
day I'm super jet fan good news the only
thing I put on camera the level of the
level of disrespect that I have for them
they I love them by the way a lot of
them might make more money correct great
continued success well we'll be in touch
I will I'll be in touch yeah
where we going you're going to speak up
you're up okay
simple who are you we both have longer
beards than normal everybody has a voice
now like and that voice can travel and
everybody's opinion has way more weight
than it did a decade ago and so when you
play that out what I've noticed is
something pretty scary
which is over the last five years forget
about even the election the enormous
minority of unhappy people in our
society are dramatically louder and are
impacting us more than the far majority
of us that are happy and good and that's
it and I think I almost feel this weird
sense of responsibility for somebody who
can tweet and have lots of people show
up to have that many people paying
attention to what I'm talking about
there's only so much I can do about
being happy and documenting my happy
journey I'm trying to pressure the other
people that are happy to talk about it
too I just think we're in a very awkward
time I think it's rubbernecking and it's
just the way it is right like we pay
more attention to the negative than the
positive it's just how I feel about the
world like I think I think human beings
are the most underrated thing of all
time when I think about our capabilities
to eliminate each other
I'm being serious I know it's kind of a
weird place to go but like the fact that
we're still here we are hardwired in a
way that allows us to protect each other
in a net game yet the mainstream media
and the way we hear all you hear is
negativity all that mainstream media
does just tell us about the point zero
zero zero one percent worst of us I
think we as humans are going to have
some level of a sense of responsibility
that if you're in a good place it might
be good to tweet or Instagram or
snapchat about that like the volume of
negativity is just way too high in
reality of what's going on and I think
the silent majority of us and this is
what happens every Empire Falls when the
silent majority of happy isn't loud
enough and they lose the branding game
gary vaynerchuck everybody
the other variable is I don't think we
can pin it all right I don't think the
other III don't think is I don't think
it's as easy as that by the way I would
tell you one of the reasons we probably
went cold turkey was because I became
not interested in having that
conversation you know if I really think
about it you know what I mean like at
some level we just should really follow
my blueprint because I'm good at it you
know so one of things we really want to
do with dailyvee is create a little bit
more color commentary on top of some of
the things that you guys are seeing how
do i layer more context around some of
the conversations you're picking up that
big one thing that you've seen over the
last couple of episodes isn't the
talking to Brandon a lot more during
vacation you know bran is my best friend
and I and so it's fun to talk to him
when I have downtime leads into Wine
Library talk and I've been very very
very m.i.a in the wine library
environment of 2016 when 2015 was the
first year I was kind of back into it
after three years and we had a very
successful year I create a different
strategy and framework we made a lot
more money and it kind of reminded my
dad Brandon and definitely even myself
that hey maybe I'm good at this business
thing it's been interesting to watch us
deviate a little bit for my structure in
the first eight months of this year and
we felt the effects we've not done as
well and so you know I think one thing
I'm fascinated by is that even though
Brandon somebody I've known through
since I was 14 even though Brandon is
somebody that I work with every day to
what the feedback he's been giving me
even though you have a religion you
still have to go and pray whether that's
on Saturday Sunday Friday like you still
have to remind yourself you can't just
say I'm religious and then just limit
it's like working out
it's forever great you had two good
years of working out and eating well if
you let it go you're gonna go right back
to where you are and so this continuity
this consistency this never wavering
never deviating from the strategy it's
tiring it's exhausting it's also
unfortunately for all of us the cost of
entering to be successful the second you
stop you could have won two Olympic
golds but if you didn't try as hard
because you weren't as hungry
somebody else is you show up and you
come an eight it's just the way it is
and so it's been a lot of fun trying to
remind Brandon on key themes which is
most things don't matter trust your
people go fast as much as you think
you're doing you can do a lot more and
and watching the results at bay at Wine
Library over the last three weeks has
been a rewarding and intoxicating I love
the action of retail and and and it's
fun when you have multiple things going
on a lot of those themes have been
motivating me in the trenches at
vaynermedia and making me look at myself
on myself I'm analyzing myself as if I
was analyzing Brandon and I'm like
tweaking things here and there and so
it's it's been a you know it's been
really fun to get back on the field
after a couple weeks of vacation
it's very refreshed very focused and and
very much zeroed in on the things that
matter as we go into the fourth quarter
good all right good
yeah